what up guys you can now listen to JK
news on a podcast go in the description
below and you can click one of those
links and don't forget to rate us as
many stars as possible so if we could do
50 presses on 5 stars and that way we
could finally get Joe Rogan on this
[ __ ]
[Music]
in marketing moves news that was like
marketing data smuggling submitted by
Morgan Lee loves you
[ __ ] you don't love me [ __ ]
I didn't consent to being loved okay
love me
dominoes and IHOP are exporting the
internet outrage cycle what's in the
first let's talk about dominoes okay
whoa whoa whoa whoa I didn't make
Patrick pizza with Domino's no it's not
a matter of its two separate stories you
know what I need to be you know what I'm
really outraged as the Domino's guide
the weird dude with the [ __ ] rabbit
costume or whatever it was a superhero
Domino's superhero he had that red [ __ ]
he's gone see you guys don't even know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking thirty years
ago see he was a rabbit it was like a
Domino's superhero I know what he's
talking about I just I want to sound old
okay so don't [ __ ] act like you don't
know that's what I'm mad about you be
Domino the Marvel hero no Domino's Pizza
okay
Domino's cuz that's what came up with it
and like the McDonald's Moon Man dude
[ __ ] miss these guys man oh yeah
you're right wait no this was a video
game right oh yeah yeah yeah look what
you did Joe look what you did anyway it
looks like an evil version of the tick
oh yeah living as part of Domino's I
think is part of something else and did
a collab I think you probably did a
collab that sounds like it makes more
sense memory jealous
alright so Domino
has a video for me to show you here we
go yeah we're doing so Papa make a
better pizza instead of thank you hey do
their pizzas rockin I love Domino's it
destroys your pizza was pretty bad
have you guys had those roundtable
personal pizzas but that's not part of
the Domino's Pizza debate I know but I'm
saying I forgot that you're the fat guy
yeah I forgot that you were the bad guy
you're so skinny now I know what I'm
talking about ever been to round Table
Pizza no that's where you had pizza
parties as kids so the round tables
what's up [ __ ]
why I only had it recently and I had
like the personal pizza for a video yeah
and I assume that round table was gonna
be [ __ ] [ __ ] I thought right ate that
[ __ ] oh my [ __ ] mind
were you just no that's where you go to
have beautiful I haven't had in a minute
though I'm saying like it's been a while
and I had it when I was a kid that's
like I said pizza parties the kid wears
really there's not that many in SoCal
and I'm not talking about that DiGiorno
[ __ ] Little Caesars not gonna talk about
that I've ever want Domino's right three
years ago my roommate used to work at
Domino's but you hated that roommate so
that's why you have really
Mel's like cheese Domino's is good
that's why you don't like it I always
didn't like dominos even when they put
the [ __ ] seasoning on the bread crust
if I was if I was crawling in the desert
right and there's nothing to eat for
miles and crawling and fallen corn they
come across a DiGiorno pizza there's not
enough grease I say this though that
pizza was delicious
there's Arnold plenty bob was got a
surprise I'm eating it up for her how
dare you
no I'm just waiting but the fact that I
know my friends are getting paid for it
made it taste better
yeah because like legitimately I wanted
to hate it and it was good it was good
guess what Steve your pants were down
buddy
you got me cuz I won't be a corporate
sponsor I wanted to hate that pizza so
bad I'd bit into I spit it out and ate
it again I know it's gonna be good it
was I just smelled it and I'm just knew
the [ __ ] corner edges dude like wait
is that Joe's inflection or is that
Bart's inflation which one the one he
just did it like I didn't I didn't know
if I liked it but then I liked it okay
look that's the Joe I thought but then
you just did it so I'm like who's is it
delivery is they have their own chicken
an egg exactly I understand why food
companies always sponsor people who just
don't eat what do you mean yeah case in
point are you talking about Keith you
evil one hey that's only half of the
equation that's true the other spot to
you then I I know own food places you
know god damn it I cook all the [ __ ]
time I have a [ __ ] food show you say
god damn it and [ __ ] [ __ ] and
[ __ ] so I know how to speak
English what the [ __ ] people that cussed
me - E - yeah America has to happen to
that demographic [ __ ] - or nah I
would legit trust like the guy there's
there's a guy who like eat pizza every
single day out there and they're a
hoarder and they [ __ ] are surrounded
by pizza boxes I want that guy to be
like this is the best he should be the
he should be this
you can't tell I eat a lot of Pizza yeah
cuz those guys they smell like pizza
sweat breads are so [ __ ] dumb -
they're like actually I take that back
kinda halfway because I want to be
sponsored but it's like they figure
you're not brand friendly everybody eats
food what the [ __ ] are you talking about
everybody eats food whether you're a
piece of [ __ ] a rapist of murder
everybody's food yeah what about the
rapist demographic dude they got Jeffrey
Dahmer and Jeffrey Dahmer's like I'm
Jeffrey Dahmer and as you know I've
eaten a lot of lot of interesting things
in my life and he's like and the best
seasoning is Old Bay why you're
close-minded
exactly and you hate good branding like
McDonald's hates fat people exactly and
you are the reason why people like that
yeah makes no sense so you should fund
[ __ ] why is he why can't one fat person
appear in a McDonald's commercial not
one not a single fat purses on
McDonald's ever and that's their whole
clientele that's why I'm say commercials
don't make sense I just saw infinity
commercial of Steph Curry and I'm like
what does basketball have to do with the
[ __ ] he doesn't even drive at
infinity yeah you have a [ __ ] Ferrari
and Lambo well let's get back to
Domino's here put a [ __ ] uber driver
in there and have his car is there will
be a dope infinity commercial where
Steph Curry's in there and he calls it
over or do get a porn star and it's like
yo I [ __ ] in a lot of cars but this is
the most comfortable and luxurious
there's so much room in the back if
that's the most ability control we
didn't we did all of every position you
can imagine in this car you should do it
with just super cinematic till I get
round all the time guts glory
ramp suspensions great [ __ ] yeah that's
W good time
no wait what does I have to my heart it
turned into a harbor just finished I was
really quick I've been well I don't get
what the outrage is there is no outrage
anywhere I thought you started it with
there on the internet outraged the
headline so you know how like did she I
didn't hear [ __ ] you did it oh yeah the
reason for that headline is because the
Internet is just they like to talk a lot
right just like right now we are talking
a lot and we're on the internet so
anyway phone the whole pot whole thing
they've been stamping it all over the
country they've been so they're outraged
about Wow that is [ __ ] genius because
otherwise the everywhere pretty much so
they're fixing it but then putting their
[ __ ] logo on there that's amazing you
guys together the next level so I hop
though so this is the whole I hop thing
that happened they announced that they
were changing their name from I hopped
aha i hub and it was like speculation
where does the B stand for people that
are Xmas people thought it was bacon but
it turns out it's higher harbor now it
really they closed their Instagram
account in the dorm younger dog
they might be [ __ ] with us cuz I went
on went on their Instagram and an IHOP
was closed and they're like well I hob
now Oh am I gonna get the fruity Tooty
fresh and fruity I never think I hop and
burgers always think I hop and breakfast
food yeah maybe that's what they want
you to know this isn't that I feel like
I know they still have breakfast food
though this is not America we are saying
that the name change is in effect for
the time being so I it's just a whole
marketing thing but there are some
stores that have the IHOP now that blew
my mind I thought they were doing that
for real you know some of the brings
look good though that's why maybe they
want people to know hey we got burgers
too but no one goes there for the
burgers 24/7 it's pancakes breakfast
like wife they don't Denny's does then
he smashes them dad breakfast I think
Danny smashed I can't drag Nicky to a
Denny's
I hate Denny's I'm a mess I'm not saying
Denny's is better I'm saying Denny's is
there's more people that go to Denny's
in ion that's yours what one you depict
DRAM and I'm looking for pancakes I look
for IHOP because daddy's is cheaper I
guess he could be drunk as [ __ ] and I
take I try to drag her nude and he's
like no no oh yeah and she's like I'll
eat anything I don't give a [ __ ] like
ten minutes before I'm sick no no I'm
not eating this but I hop is here and
Denny's is here it's not that different
come you know I hop is here I agree they
both suck to me they do suck but one
sucks wave remember to qualify TIFF cos
hurt to hurt there's our pizza's here
and then it's like [ __ ] lovely locked
lobster down here like TIFF went to
[ __ ] Italy a she went back into the
kitchen took the pizza out threw a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]